notre invité politique ce matin c'est
patrick mignola bonjour je vous remercie
beaucoup d'être avec nous député de la
savoie président du groupe modèle à
l'assemblée nationale on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par stéphane bern
et bonjour stéphane bonjour garde
stéphane qui dirige le bureau parisien
du journal ouest france on commence par
la crise sanitaire patrick mignola
puisque les associations d'élus et les
groupes parlementaires doivent remettre
aujourd'hui leurs propositions à jean
castex sur la vaccination obligatoire
sur l'élargissement du passé ni terre ou
encore sur l' isolement des personnes
contaminées
quelles sont vos propositions patrick
mignola on va peut-être commencer par la
vaccination
question il faut dire 1 quel est le
risque aujourd'hui on peut être saisie
d'un énorme risque avec le variant delta
qui à la fois sera courir de nouveau des
risques à la santé des français et à la
reprise de l'économie française avec
toutes les conséquences sociales que ça
peut avoir
quel est le besoin il faut qu'on accepte
de faire quelque chose qui est
probablement trop inhabituel en
politique faut qu'on dise aux français
qu'on a besoin d'eux qu'on a besoin de
leurs responsabilités que chacun porte
une partie du destin de l'autre qu'ils
ont sur les épaules sur leurs épaules où
ils peuvent se faire vacciner
la capacité à protéger leurs concitoyens
et donc il faut qu'on en tire un certain
nombre de conséquences et nous sommes
très largement favorable à l'assemblée à
ce qu'un texte rapide dans les jours qui
viennent puissent donner l'autorisation
au gouvernement de nous proposer au vote
l'obligation vaccinale pour les
professionnels les plus exposés
ce que moi je veux pas stigmatiser les
soignants en particulier je j'entends
bien sur le terrain que il ya beaucoup
de françaises et français qui ne
comprennent pas comment ceux qui
s'occupent des plus vulnérables
pourraient refuser la vaccination mais
vous avez vous finalement dans une
réglementation qui est assez bien fait
dans toutes les mairies on a des
établissements qui reçoivent du public
les oeufs rp et bien chaque fois qu'on a
un établissement recevant du public de
5e de 4e de troisième catégorie c'est de
dire les professionnels doivent être
vaccinés ça c'est l'obligation vaccinale
et puis ceux qui le fréquentent nos va
voir le pass sanitaire pas sanitaire ça
peut être la vaccination
ça peut être un cosy dont on s'est remis
ou ça peut être un test mais sur les
tests il faut qu'on aille plus loin pour
que les choses soient très claires on
doit sortir de la gratuité des tests
lorsqu'à une ordonnance de la part des
médecins bah c'est tout à fait normal on
est dans un parcours médical et
naturellement il faut que le test soit
gratuit mais en revanche on peut pas le
laisser le choix d'être une sorte de
passager clandestin dans la gestion de
la crise sanitaire ou à la fois on veut
pas de la vaccination
et puis on va se faire multi tester tous
les jours ou toutes les semaines
quand il s'agit d'un test donc les
enceintes est de confort est payant pour
les personnes non vaccinées
voilà exactement juste un mot pardon sur
les personnes que vous souhaitez voir
éligibles à la vaccination obligatoire
donc aller chagnon les personnes qui
sont en contact du public
est ce que ça veut dire que ça doit
aller jusqu aux enseignants par exemple
assez naturellement pour la rentrée moi
je souhaite que les enseignants puissent
être vaccinés
pourquoi on commence à l'actionner de
manière obligatoire
je vais vous expliquer en fait le la
problématique plus on laisse le virus se
propage et aiguë et plus on sent qu'à
chaque fois le virus prend des
propriétés différentes notamment des
propriétaires en termes de contagion qui
sont différentes la le variant delta
c'est six fois plus contagieux que
l'était le variant anglais le variant
angles est en lui-même deux fois plus
contagieux que le virus initial si
demain nous avons un virus qui peut
atteindre les enfants ce qui devient une
hypothèse scientifique qui a désormais
étudie avec beaucoup d'attention
moi je peux pas imaginer que dans six
mois la société française se retrouve de
nouveau face à la pandémie avec deux
nouveaux deux des services d'urgence
surchargé et de surcroît avec un virus
qui peut tuer des enfants
donc il faut qu'on soit tous en
responsabilité est qu'on se donne les
outils législatifs pour faire vous
pourrez très clair en septembre
vaccination obligatoire des enseignants
et le les soignants aujourd'hui et après
en fonction de l'évolution laisser la
possibilité aux gouvernants exactement
comme l'état d'urgence sanitaire
on a laissé la possiblité au
gouvernement de faire un confinement
total un confinement partiel
un confinement territorialisée des
mesures de couvre-feu sur la vaccination
il faut qu'on soit exactement dans les
mêmes dispositions
c'est à dire que tant que le virus
circule à bas bruit dire on n'est pas
obligé de passer à l'obligation
vaccinale complète
en revanche on peut sur le plan
territorialisée ou par secteur
d'activité parce qu'on peut penser
également aux questions des forces de
l'ordre
on peut poser la question sur les
personnels des collectivités locales
toutes celles et ceux qui sont dans des
lieux où il ya beaucoup de monde le
virus de toute façon il agit là où il ya
beaucoup de monde donc partout où il ya
beaucoup de monde
les professionnels doivent être vaccinés
et les usagers doivent présenter impasse
alors là ce que vous nous présentez
c'est votre façon de voir les choses est
ce que c'est ça la position officielle
du modèle aujourd'hui c'est celle qu'on
est en train de dire à la willis a fait
la trique au sein du groupe modem et
vous avez entendu le france au bo en
général entre le parti modem et le
groupe modem il arrive qu'on soit ces
corps alors quand vous disiez tout à
l'heure nous à l'assemblée c'est le
terme que vous avez utilisé est-ce qu'il
ya un large consensus entre les groupes
parlementaires à l'assemblée et au sénat
sur ce que vous venez de présenter ou
est ce que ça va faire débat je vais
vous dire sans malice mais pète avec un
petit peu de malice quand même que
j'aimerais bien savoir ce qu'est la
position des autres groupes parce que je
vois bien que dans la majorité vous
l'exprimer mais les autres la volonté de
s'exprimer d'assumer
depuis jeudi dernier qu'on a été
consulté par le premier ministre un
certain nombre de groupes d'opposition
ont pris des positions qui étaient des
positions personnelles et j'entendais le
sénateur bas tout à l'heure pour lequel
j'ai de l'estimé dire à peu près une
chose l inverse
moi je pense qu'il faut dire des choses
simples et claires il faut que le
politique assume sa responsabilité face
à la pandémie
on peut pas dire ah oui vaudrait mieux
que tout le monde soit vacciné ram et en
même temps vous comprenez c'est un peu
difficile de l'imposer c'est pas
difficile de l'imposer vous avez tous
les pays du monde qui ont une politique
en matière de vaccination le l'italie à
proximité immédiate de la savoie
à décider par exemple que pour les
soignants évidemment que on a toujours
le choix on va pas mettre un pistolet
derrière la nuque de chacun mais les
soignants qui ne souhaitent pas se faire
vacciner maintenant ce que l'oeil ne
viennent pas travailler chacun est libre
mais est-ce que vous avec le livre de
contaminer les personnes vulnérables
peut aller jusqu'à la vaccination
obligatoire pour tous telle que la
recommande ou la suggère françois bayrou
alors le votre position en fait il dit
une chose très simple françois bayrou
mais je suis complètement d'accord avec
ça au fond j'ai l'impression qu'on a
tous oublié qu'en réalité on y tous
vaccinés mais à onze vaccination
quand on fait un bébé et quand lorsque
l'enfant paraît il ya onze vaccin qui
lui sont administrés
il ya des tests génétiques à six tests
génétiques qui dit qui lui sont faits
mais au fond tout ça c'est l'histoire de
la civilisation et ce sont aussi les
vaccins se repose pas sur la même
technologie là parce que la technologie
arn est très nouvelle
oui vous avez une nouvelle technologie
qui sortent notamment avec sanofi et
c'est vraiment une très bonne nouvelle
que sanofi puisse la voir
mais vous savez très bien aussi et bien
sûr on peut toujours craindre que des
techniques nouvelles
mais on peut pas être rétrograde il ya
le les découverts sur la rn messagers
sont porteurs de ce port tous deux de
très grands espoirs notamment pour la
lutte contre un certain nombre de
cancers
donc il faut arrêter de se faire peur
aujourd'hui rendez compte on avait les
animations pour tous on a vacciné 3
milliard d'êtres humains 3 milliards
d'êtres humains et c'est un des vaccins
qui a le moins d'effets secondaires
indésirables et donc vous êtes pour la
région quasiment obligatoire pour moi je
suis attaché aux libertés publiques et
donc je pense que la vaccination
obligatoire pour tous et tout de suite
bien c'est un pas qu'il est difficile de
franchir pour les français en revanche
dire aux français on se laisse la
possibilité de faire une obligation
vaccinale pour certains publics pour
certaines concessions et on a bien sûr
certains usagers et ben ce moment là
qu'on regarde la courbe de la
vaccination on regarde la courbe
du virus est en fonction on prend les
décisions et on s'adapte sujet sur
lequel jean castex vous consulte
notamment le pass sanitaire est ce qu'il
faut élargir le passage du ter au delà
des rassemblements plus de mille
personnes est ce qu'il faut le mettre en
oeuvre pour les actes de la vie
quotidienne ça paraît absolument évident
et dans ce cas il faut le faire de façon
territorialisées c'est à dire que enfin
dans les espaces où le virus circule
c'est à dire où on atteint un taux de
contamination qui dépassent un certain
nombre de codes d' alerte il ya un
certain nombre d'activités de la vie
sociale qui devaient être soumises au
pass sanitaires s'ils ont des regrets la
liberté un sa surface offrait à
discrétion des préfets à nouveau oui
j'ai l'impréssion 1 3 il faut que ce
soit à l'échelle des ars des préfets de
région à l'échelle des préfets de
département et de dire en fonction des
activités vous voyez bien que il va y
avoir un certain nombre d'activités
estivales
selon qu'on est balnéaire où ce nom
qu'on a en vacances à la montagne pour
éclairer son voilà on a là il faut faire
ça c'est clair il s'agit juste d'
abaisser le seuil de à partir duquel on
monte on exige le pass sanitaire
aujourd'hui c'est plus de 1000 personnes
demain c'est avec moi plus de 500 places
en louer j'étais aux rencontres
économiques d'aix-en-provence la semaine
dernière où on était 999 donc on était
en dessous de l'âge et le passé dentaire
été demandée à chacun chacun les
restaurants par exemple qui ont créé l
autre il faut il faut laisser à chaque
territoire français y a rien de pire que
de revenir toujours la même chose genre
politique on demande de prendre les
grandes décisions nationales qui ont su
it sont inapplicables ou mal appliquées
sur le terrain
exercez vous partez d'un principe simple
aujourd'hui impasse sanitaires pour des
jo-2000 ébats selon les régions selon
les départements en fonction de
l'évolution du virus
on s'adapte humilité responsabilité et
dans ce cas là peut-être conduire à la
jauge est à 500 la jauge est à 200 ou la
jauge va porter sur tel ou tel événement
d'actualité tels ou tels festivals tel
ou tel rassemblement touristiques
balnéaires rassemblement touristique en
montagne
et ça les français le comprennent
parfaitement le virus circule là où il
ya beaucoup de monde donc quand il ya
beaucoup de monde on prend les
dispositions les restaurants le
restaurant par contre maintenant parce
que le problème c'est que le cahier de
présence ne marche pas du tout
aujourd'hui dans l'histoire personne ne
l'utilisent je vais vous dire c'est ce
qu'il faut si demain en effet proposer
quelque chose relève tant rire des
situations c'est à dire où il y avait
une
nouvelle flambée de virus il faut se
laisser la possibilité de faire en sorte
que les français qui sont vaccinées
puisse aller au restaurant et que
d'autres ne le puissent pas s'ils
peuvent pas présenter un pass sanitaires
c'est à dire qu'on va pas se remettre à
congeler la france à fermer les bars et
les restaurants
parce qu'on n'aura pas su suffisamment
convaincre les français nous avons
besoin de nous avons besoin qu'ils se
vaccine
et si demain il doit y avoir un nouveau
confinement il faudra laisser les
activités économiques ouverte en
particulier les bars et les restaurants
mais simplement on ne pourra y aller que
si on est vaccinés oui emmanuel macron
réunit aujourd'hui les partenaires
sociaux ils vont parler de la réforme
des retraites
évidemment donc est-ce qu'il faut la
remettre sur la table dès maintenant est
ce que le tempo est bon ou est-ce que
c'est pas particulièrement dangereux
dans la perspective de l'élection
présidentielle 2022
et je vais vous dire que c'est pas
interdit d'avoir du courage et donc
évidemment qu'il faut à la prod la
dernière fois ça c'est pas très bien que
c'est le sujet et bah oui mais c'est le
principe de la politique ou et pas faire
que les trucs qui sont forcément
plaisant retrouve maintenant avec
l'année on est obligé de le rouvrir
maintenant moi je pense que on ne pourra
pas aller au bout d'une réforme complète
et responsable avant l'élection
présidentielle mais revanche pour ouvrir
le débat maintenant pour que tout le
monde puisse se positionner dessus avec
ce qui s'est passé depuis 18 mois
la question c'est de savoir si on
réforme de l'ir les retraites pour les
équilibres et dans 15 ans c'est pour
savoir si dans trois ou quatre ans on
pourra encore servir les pensions au
niveau où elles sont aujourd'hui aux
retraités d'aujourd'hui
je pense qu'en face de ça il faut qu'on
mette des conditions c'est à dire que si
on dit tous et puis les français s'y
attendre ils attendent qu'un jour il ya
un président de la république qui
viennent au journal de 20h équilibre
écouter pour sauver le modèle social
français va falloir qu'on travaille tous
18 mois de plus oui mais en plus en 10
ans de toute façon on doit ouvrir ce
débat
pour les neuf mois qui viennent et que
chacun se positionne dessus on entendu
que marine le pen voulait garder la
retraite à 60 ans le s'agissant de
l'opposition de droite je n'ai pas tout
à fait compris là encore il ya une
espèce de petit jeu d'habileté ou une
chose et son contraire c'est simple en
1980 on partait à la retraite a mis à 65
ans aujourd'hui on part à la retraite à
62 ans alors qu'on vit quinze ans de
plus il n'y a pas besoin d'être un grand
expert pour se dire qu'il va falloir
tous avoir une durée de cotisation un
peu plus large simplement il faut qu'en
face on met des mesures de justice
il faut régler enfin le problème des
agriculteurs commerçants artisans et de
leurs conjoints qui peuvent pas avoir
des retraites aussi minable alors qu'ils
ont travaillé toute leur vie
et puis il faut qu'on règle le problème
de l'autonomie et de la dépendance et
c'est un deuxième chantier qui nous faut
lancer dès maintenant pour qu'il
aboutisse dans la prochaine législature
parce que on à la première génération de
famille qui paye les ehpad de ses
parents en même temps que les études de
ses enfants
alors parfois on se dit avec des grandes
réflexions sciences politiques mais
pourquoi les français n'ont pas le moral
bas vous rendez compte y paye d'abord un
logement très cher dans chaque budget
familial kazim à hauteur de 40 % des
revenus et puis ils paient aussi l'ehpad
des parents est aussi l'étude des
enfants cyr quand vous vous levez le
matin vous travaillez pour l'état
jusqu'à midi ensuite vous travaillez
jusqu'à 14h pour votre logement jusqu'à
16 heures pour payer les enfants et les
grands parents et vous commencé à bosser
pour vous à partir de 16 heures
on peut pas rester dans cette situation
est clairement est ce qu'un manuel mâcon
doit venir dire ça devant les français
lancé ses réformes de la retraite de
l'autonomie de la dépendance d'ici le 14
juillet est ce que c'est ça que vous
attendez du président de la république
aux logiques de bouger ou que nous on
chez eux donné parce que je crois c'est
que notre majorité a besoin de dire aux
français
là où on a besoin d'arriver dans un an
et dans dix ans et on a besoin dans
l'année qui vient d'ouvrir tous ces
débats pour que l'élection
présidentielle ne se fasse pas sur des
sur des castings ou des petites phrases
mais se fasse sur la vie des français
on vient de lui des élections
départementales et régionales où on
entendu parler que de sécurité et
d'éoliennes c'était vraiment très très
nul très très nul
eh bien il faut que on passe l'élection
présidentielle sur la question de
comment demain
les français qui sont au chômage peuvent
être mieux formés pour aller vers les
nouveaux métiers qui sont créés par le
plan de relance il faut que en
responsabilité on dise combien de temps
il nous faudra travailler en plus pour
sauver le modèle social français
et puis enfin il faudra un troisième
pilier qu'est celui de la démocratie
et comment on ré intéresse les français
à l'espace démocratique de leur pays en
est un des pays qui a inventé la
démocratie est aujourd'hui les français
s'en détournent juste emmanuel macron va
vous recevoir vous parlementaires de la
majorité
je cours je crois que c'est la semaine
prochaine si j'ai bien compris je suis
en a pas encore reçu d'invitation mais
on devrait y répondre au général comme
président de la république nous a vite
on y va les sénateurs et les députés ne
parviennent toujours pas à se mettre
d'accord sur le texte visant à inscrire
la protection de l'environnement dans
l'article 1er de la constitution
[Musique]
du coup y'a pas de référendum possible
pour le moment quelle est votre position
par rapport aux quel est votre regard
par rapport à ça est ce que vous
comprenez que le débat soit soit bloquée
moi j'ai un regard qui est celui de mes
enfants
dix ou douze enfants ne comprennent pas
la querelle sémantique on prend on
propose quoi on propose d'inscrire
l'environnement dans la constitution
j'entends le les querelles se sémantique
au juridique dur mais vous comprenez si
on met garantit rien risme enfin lisons
la constitution la constitution utilise
le mot garantir à de nombreuses reprises
la première fois d'ailleurs ce que le la
république garantit l'expression
pluraliste
donc pour vous c'est un faux problème
évidemment on fait ce que vous avez déjà
vu quelqu'un un citoyen un électeur une
association un lobby emmené le le
gouvernement dans un procès parce qu'il
n'assurerait pas l'expression pluraliste
des courants politiques pourtant ce
serait le cas puisque on renonce
toujours à faire le scrutin
proportionnel des mais personne ne fait
ça bien
emmanuel macron avait lors de ces trois
jokers vous rappelez elle vit à trois
jokers que je ne prends pas c'est à dire
que je n'en ai 3 c'était je ne souhaite
pas mettre la protection de
l'environnement au dessus des libertés
fondamentales
c'était la modification du préambule
mais que dans l'article 1er on fasse
figurer le l'environnement c'est
l'évidence alors je vois bien que une
sorte de jeu de dupes où nous explique
que aulas l'assemblée prendre des
risques parce qu'elle veut mettre
garantie le sénat veut mettre à j moi je
regrette quand même que c'est le il faut
pas que le sénat sur le plan des
réformes institutionnelles fasse le même
travail que la cgt sur les réformes
sociales on est d'accord sur le fond
mais un autre projet peu sont en train
de comparer le sait à la cgt c'est sa
mère l'aurait l'occurrence c'est moi ce
jeu j'observe que on avait besoin c'est
comme ça quand on est arrivé aux
responsabilités que nous le disions on
avait besoin d'avoir de vastes réformes
institutionnelles simplifier le
mille-feuille territorial auquel
personne ne comprend rien on voit bien
les résultats que ça a donné avec un
assez large désintérêt des électeurs
pour les élections départementales et
régionales
c'est grave pour moi qui ai été élu
local pendant 20 ans
j'avais besoin de faire la
proportionnelle et à chaque fois on a
achoppé rapidement sur le millefeuille
territorial puisque françois bayrou
dimanche je disais que ça allait pas la
région nouvelle aquitaine saint-vaast de
poche qu'un poitiers en passant par
l'image ça va pas est ce qu'il faut
c'est son avis est-ce qu'il faut
remettre à plat la loi notre est-ce
qu'il faut revoir les régions est ce
qu'il faut aller au bout de cette
logique évidemment il faut qu'on
revienne à des régions c'est parce que
dans les élus qui sont ressenties
non mais d'abord c'est ce que demandent
les gens dire les gens il aime bien
vivre dans des collectivités qu'il faut
se trouve que la loi note de public un
sac homme était un trauma pour beaucoup
est de dire on re des tricots soul et on
recommence mais j'en étais le les lois
notre elle a produit et il est assez
c'est assez étonnant que ce soit à
l'époque puisqu'il y avait le cumul des
mandats des parlementaires qui était en
même temps élus locaux qui ont mis en
place une loi qui a donné énormément de
migraines aux élus locaux j'en étais en
a pas c'est des journées des journées
enfin et vous avez vraiment mais drôme
et vous est familière et d'un rôle à
tricoter dans la note vous avez un seau
nombre de dispositions qui sont
techniques soit c'est le rôle des élus
c'est pour ça qu'ils auront la migraine
on va pas revenir dessus
en revanche le découpage ya une région
qui rassemble à la fois auvergne et
rhône alpes
j'aime beaucoup le vernis mon épouse il
ya vécu et moi j'étais en savoie donc
finalement il ya des formes de liens qui
peuvent rapprocher les deux régions mais
imaginez qu'on peut travailler sur la
question des transports de la même façon
à aurillac et à chamonix
c'est une vue de l'esprit un monsieur
éric dupond marie sy mairie du monde
donc le garde des sceaux convoqué dans
10 jours par la cour de la justice de la
cour de justice de la république en vue
d'une possible mise en examen
qu'est ce qui va se passer ça vous
paraît possible qu'est ce que quel est
le regard que vous portez sur cette
affaire
très sévère très sévère pour qui pour
nos institutions qui sont complètement
dysfonctionnelle quand vous avez dans
une république
un conseil d'état qui fait de la
politique à la place du gouvernement un
conseil constitutionnel qui jugent
parfois beaucoup plus en opportunité
quand constitutionnalité et que vous
avez des syndicats de magistrats qui
déposent des plaintes contre leur garde
des sceaux en vue de le changer
je pense qu'on est bien malade et c'est
peut-être aussi pour ça que les gens
vont pas voter il faut quand même un
moment qu'on se remettre la tête à
l'endroit
est-ce qu'on va pas remettre un peu
d'ordre dans ce pays et dire que chacun
doit faire son boulot jeu
extrêmement graves pourraient pas
intéressé les français si on continue
d'avoir des institutions enfin on n'est
pas en république depuis trois ans on
n'est pas dans une sorte d' immaturité
de mise en place institutionnelle toute
récente ou ou en confondrait les
responsabilités des uns et des autres
que chacun fasse son boulot il ya une
autre juridiction administrative
il ya une haute juridiction
constitutionnelle et il ya au sein du
ministère de la justice une obligation
c'est de mettre plus de justice dans le
pays parce que c'est ça que les gens
attendent c'est d'aller plus vite quand
on rend des décisions de justice et
c'est pas d'organiser des querelles et
des contentieux judiciaires entre
l'administration centrale du ministère
de la justice et les syndicats de
magistrats
à un moment le rôle du politique c'est
de se remettre un peu la tête à
l'endroit
un dernier mot patrick mignola une
question un peu plus d'organisation de
recomposition de la majorité
présidentielle vous allez nous dire les
élections régionales et départementales
ont été un coup dur un coup de semonce a
même dit françois bayrou pour la
majorité sur la majorité présidentielle
grave échec
vous entendez les voix de côté la
république en marche remettre un peu en
question le fonctionnement
du mouvement est ce que pour vous il
faut aller plus loin est ce qu'il faut
en finir avec la république en marche le
modem à giresse qu'il faut recomposer
cette majorité présidentielle dans un
grand mouvement dans un grand parti
il faut dire pourquoi faire la première
chose à faire c'est l'identification des
familles politiques
elles doivent être identifiés ce vaste
espace central qui a été provoquée
organisée par emmanuel macron au fond
gris qui a donné la possibilité d'un
centre en france est composée des
sociaux démocrates des centristes des
libéraux
ces trois familles doivent être
présentés et on doit pouvoir les
identifier que chaque français puisse
identifier
kylie a désormais un monde politique
multipolaire parce que eux-mêmes peuvent
avoir des des sensibilités diverses et 2
c'est à ça aussi servent les partis
politiques ça sert à s'ouvrir à d'autres
et si ce grand espace doit être le
rassemblement des modérés des deux rives
et bat organisons le lorient on
l'organisera mieux donc si on resserre
nos liens ce que je souhaite évidemment
c'est non seulement pour que l'on soit
plus identifiés aux yeux des français
merci aussi pour créer des liens avec
d'autres parce que vous savez quand d'un
côté on est une gauche qui fait des
débats abscons sur universalisme
intersectionnelle isme et une droite qui
a pas fini de débattre notamment dans sa
primaire à venir entre une ligne
conservatrice traditionalistes et une
ligne libérale et bien moi je pense
qu'on a la possibilité d'ouvrir très
largement les bras et à défaut d'aller
vers deux français sur trois en tout cas
composer une majorité efficace mais dans
un parti unique nommé le parti unique ça
n'a jamais marché un bien de la gauche a
essayé la droite a essayé on sait
comment ça finit
moi je souhaite que mon travail dans des
alliances entre des gens qui peuvent
être différents nous savait avant le bio
disait de delors elle est dure ba
aujourd'hui de ferran à philippe en
allant même un peu toujours un différend
à gauche et un peu plus loin de philippe
à droite on doit être capable de
réformer ce pays pour la décennie qui
vient
merci beaucoup merci patrick mignola
d'avoir été notre invité merci stéphane
on regarde là
de ouest-france vaccination contre le
coc vite faut-il la rendre obligatoire
c'est la question à la une de ouest
france merci stéphane à demain et merci
beaucoup patrick mignola
[Musique]